Europe's Common Agricultural Policy the
cap comes under the microscope when
European farm ministers meet on April
22nd the cap helps guaranteed good
living standards for farmers and stable
food suppliers at fair prices for
consumers it also Foster's rural
development and protects the environment
but it accounts for a big slice of the
EU budget at their meeting in Luxembourg
the minister's will be briefed on the
outcome of the first try log
negotiations between the council
parliament and commission since the
council and the Parliament reached
positions on the cap reform package last
month those talks focused on the rules
governing direct payments to farmers the
organisation of markets in agricultural
products rural development support and
the way the cap is financed managed and
monitored if all goes according to plan
do you use Irish presidency hopes to
clinch a comprehensive political Accord
on the reforms by june 30 the Commission
will also present a plan to the
ministers for transitional measures for
next year as the farm package could not
be implemented before 2015 in fisheries
talks the Commission will also unveil an
action plan to reduce the number of
accidental catches of seabirds in
fishing gear these incidents have become
a threat to some bird populations most
involve the use of long line and static
nets
ministers will also hold a public debate
on the first trial of negotiations
between the council Commission and
Parliament on reforming the e use common
fisheries policy the presidency would
like the council to come back on some of
the sensitive issues raised during the
discussions with the other institutions